islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
i mean it doesn't get stronger than this
and yet you want to be careful
about your language
you're happy
to correctly use
the most strong and robust language
to describe the crimes against humanity
of vladimir putin but you will not use
the same strength of language when it
comes to describing the israel israel's
treatment of the palestinians when it is
now being documented and detailed by two
of the most uh respected human rights
organizations in the world and indeed
has been alleged by dozens and dozens of
non-governmental organizations
and to be honest anybody who looks
honestly at the decades of brutal
inhumane persecution of the palestinian
successive assaults
on gaza the annexation of the land and
territory the systematic application of
apartheid rules
you don't want to even use the word
apartheid never mind sanctions
five days sanctions against putin and
his thugs
seventy years of oppression by the
palestinians
and it wouldn't be what was the word you
used
uh it wouldn't be helpful
to impose sanctions
uh amnesty international are calling for
israel to be referred to the
international criminal court for crimes
against humanity will you support it
they are calling for targeted sanctions
against israeli officials who are
perpetuating the system of apartheid
just
exactly the same types of sanctions
you've just initiated against flatter
vladimir putin will you support it
uh
and i think the answer is clearly you're
not going to islam net is raising funds
to establish a masjid and community
center in norway every person who prays
there every kid that learns about islam
every youngster that memorizes the quran
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of good deeds click the link
and donate what you can